seems like things are heating up between
kanye west and julia fox
but turns out the rapper is being very
purposeful with their recent pda and it
involves his ex kim kardashian you just
gotta roll with it a source tells et
that yay and julia are having a good
time hanging out and getting to know
each other better but adds quote kanye
is trying to make kim jealous by being
very public with julia he is trying to
make a point now this all follows the
two's steamy photo shoot during their
date night in new york city which
interview magazine shared photos of the
31 year old spilled the deets on how
they first met and their night out
telling the mag quote i met yay in miami
on new year's eve and it was an instant
connection julia said that she and the
donda rapper had such a good time they
quote decided to keep the energy going
and fly back to new york city to see
slave play the pair then hit up carbon
where the photo shoot took place quote
at the restaurant yay directed an entire
photo shoot for me while people dined
the whole restaurant loved it and
cheered us on while it was happening he
just
just do something for my heart an
eyewitness told et on wednesday that
kanye and julia seemed super comfortable
with each other during their night out
quote it doesn't seem like a new
relationship they seemed just happy and
at ease around each other they were deep
in conversation the whole time and
didn't seem too bothered by the fact
that there were fans and photographers
outside waiting for them it was really
surreal so what does the uncut gem star
think of yay trying to make kim jealous
well she doesn't mind our source says
quote julia thinks kanye is really cool
and is also just enjoying the ride while
it lasts i'm thankful meanwhile kim who
filed for divorce from the yeezy
designer last february is enjoying
spending time with her new boo pete
davidson after returning from their
quick trip to the bahamas a source now
tells et the pair's relationship is
really good right now adding quote he
makes her laugh plays around and has a
sense of humor it is nice for kim to be
around that i love that
that energy in my life and it turns out
et source says the kkw beauty founder
finds the snl star super sexy quote he
is the most confident guy but not cocky
it is why it works with them kim likes
how he knows so much about comedy since
that is a world she doesn't know as much
about i love that now the two have yet
to confirm their romance themselves but
it looks like things will continue to
heat up between the two i like you just
the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
[Applause]
[Music]
you